is the new M3 MacBook Pro worth it over
the M2 Max and even the M1 Max MacBook
Pro well in this video I'm going to run
a bunch of real world tests and
comparisons including SSD speed CPU
benchmarks GPU benchmarks video editing
photo editing xcode programming logic
pro music production and so much more
and with that we're also going to be
testing the thermal throttling the fan
noise and of course the battery life
because both of these are charged up to
100% And I'm going to unplug them for
this testing now first of all I want to
mention that this new space black color
is absolutely beautiful and it almost
got me to upgrade it to the new M3 Max
but we're going to see if the testing in
this video compared to my old M1 Max
which I redid all the testing on will
get me to upgrade but you know what
let's start off with a tear down
comparison to see if the thermal block
actually got bigger in this new M3 Max
model in Moment of Truth oh whoa look at
that that's something new check this out
the new M3 Max has these little oh it's
actually rubber these rubber pads and it
seems like that's probably so that if
you kind of put pressure on the back the
MacBook case so it doesn't actually make
contact so it's stopping the contact
which is very interesting but other than
that the size of the thermal block is
exactly the same compared to the M2 Max
which is interesting because Apple made
the one on the M3 Pro chip much larger
but not on this one which is weird
because this is the one that actually
got a lot better in terms of having 12
performance core is 50% more than on the
M2 Max now other than that everything
basically looks the same we still have
eight nand slots for the storage chips
with four of them being filled if you
get bigger configurations then you'll
have more of them filled um but the same
as the M2 Max the first thing we're
going to start off with is the SSD speed
with black mat magic dis speed test all
right look at that it looks like the
right speed so far is actually faster
6271 compared to 5600 on the old one so
it looks like they are using slightly
faster ssds the read speed is just about
the same 547 to 5120 so this is really
good so far and getting straight into
performance with geekbench I do want to
mention that this M3 Max has the fully
upgraded chip which has the 40 core GPU
and the 16 core CPU which means means
that you're forced into getting 48 GB of
RAM that's why we have that compared to
32 gigs on the M2 Max which came
standard with the fully unbin version so
let's go ahead and start the CPU test
and I do want to mention this goes up to
4.05 GHz compared to
3.67 but let's see if it actually hits
that in here oh look at that
4.05 it's actually hitting it on the PE
cor usage interestingly both the m M3
and the M3 Pro never hit
4.05 even though it said it technically
can I think the highest was 3.78 on the
M3 Pro chip but this M3 Max is finally
hitting it and interestingly the M2 Max
is only going up to 3.41 GHz that's a
huge difference and it looks like for
single core the new M3 Max is
17.5% faster than the M2 Max which is
actually really really impressive and
the crazy thing is I was watching this
chart and this thing spiked up to
49 watts of usage whereas the M2 Max Max
added about 35 so a lot more power usage
for just one of those tests and holy
smokes the M3 Max is
49% faster than the M2 Max that is
absolutely mindblowing this is basically
running up to the M2 Ultra in terms of
multicore performance and even more
interesting the difference between the
M2 2 Max and the M1 Max was Tiny But now
it's a massive difference and now let's
do the Metal Graphics test we have
barely any difference in terms of the
cores 38 cores on the M2 Max up to 40
now so let's see what difference we get
now with either of them and especially
the 14-in MacBook Pro the best way to
boost your multitasking workflow is with
the geminos Dual stacked monitor from
our sponsor mobile pixels which is a
game changer for multitasking workflow
allowing me to drag and drop files and
clips from the top display right into my
video editing app on the bottom all
while taking screenshots from my video
on my MacBook saving me time and money
and it's all stacked onto this compact
base which saves death space and comes
with a bunch of extra ports so check out
the gemino dual stack monitor using the
link below and for graphics it looks
like we're only getting a
99.7% raw performance increase which
isn't that good even though the GPU
wattage actually went up to 50 Watts
which is crazy compared to 38 on the M2
Max but we do have a bunch of new GPU
features including Ray tracing which
we're going to be testing in just a
minute and now let's do a real world
gaming Benchmark which is going to be
showing off those new GPU features and
seeing what kind of differences for
gaming workloads we're going to get
there you go that is what I'm talking
about 188 FPS on the M3 Max compared to
150. one that's 25% faster that's a big
difference compared to that small
geekbench difference we got and this is
actually
57% faster than my M1 Max 32 core that I
do actually use for gaming sometimes
playing War Thunder maybe I should
upgrade and now let's get into web
design using figma this is a project
provided to us by 500 designs one of the
best Design Studios over in Cali all
right the first test is to zoom in and
see how fast some some of this content
loads up that was basically instant I
didn't even see it not be sharp Let's
test it over here I'm expecting insanely
fast results as well both of them are
crazy fast for this but getting into the
main test we're actually going to export
12 of these layers at four times
resolution and see which one finishes
first and we have our scores and it
looks like the M2 Max took 10 seconds
longer so not a very big difference a
minute and 28 on the M3 Max and they
both beat out the M1 Max by quite a bit
and now let's get into programming
performance with our xcode Benchmark and
by the way it has been completely redone
so all of the old scores are no longer
compatible everything is new and the
Tesla is a little bit harder so let's
see what we get and wow programmers this
M3 Max is absolutely killing it only 79
seconds in this test the M2 Max took 39%
longer and then the M1 Max Max took 64%
longer so programmers are getting a
really good deal with this M3 Max
because it's blazing through this and
now let's get into logic pro music
production performance now this is going
to be exciting let's see how much these
can handle we're going to do 240 tracks
on each which is going to be tough oh
right away the system overloaded on the
M2 Max which basically means the CPU
couldn't handle that many tracks at once
all right guys can you hear the fan
that's the first time we've heard the
fan so far and we just played 300 and
28 tracks I don't think we've ever hit
that before and it's mind-blowing
because this stopped at
194 that's all it can run that's 69%
more tracks that it can run but get this
my M1 Max only ran
118 tracks
and you're not going to believe this
guys the M2 Ultra only handled 320
tracks compared to
328 this thing is beating the M2 Ultra
and you can get 128 gigs of unified
memory this is the ultimate workstation
in a laptop and now let's move on to
cinebench 2024 doing some CPU multicore
benchmarking and by the way we came back
the next day I closed the laptops they
both lost around 10% so everything is
still equal let's get into this all
right we got mx power Gadget look at
that 50 Watts on the M3 Max right away
only hit about 33 on the M2 Max in terms
of the progress this thing is absolutely
flying and I can actually hear the fans
wow the fans are ramping up so much
faster than they did last year
especially compared to this it's barely
barely idling wow guys the fans are
going they're like literally maxing out
the fans are basically maxing out right
now that is absolutely insane the temps
are nice and cool 96° C relatively
compared to about 103 on the M2 Max
machine the fans are still almost barely
barely running and the surprising thing
is that even though this thing has 12
performance cores compared to 8 on the
M2 max they're all running at
3.58 GHz compared to
3.26 so you got 50% more and they're
going faster surprisingly the ecores are
only going about about 2.47 compared to
2.42 not much of a difference but this
is just crazy it's been about 5 minutes
so I'm going to bust out the thermal Cam
and see how both of these are performing
in terms of temps and wow only
35° as a hot spot where the chip is
located and look at the amount of heat
right here
38° right there on the display because
that's where the fans are blowing out
39° on that spot with the Dual fans
let's check this thing out 40° C hot
spot so it is a little bit hotter on the
chip
itself and also
41° on the display so it looks like the
M3 is doing a killer job at keeping the
chip cool there you go we have our
scores and wow 1572 on the M3 Max
compared to 912 on the M2 Max that's
72% faster than the one that came out 9
months ago this is mind blowingly good
and now let's actually do the GPU test
which potentially is using Ray tracing
but we're going to see in just a second
and I do want to mention that this crazy
performance that we just got in CPU is
in a laptop that's unplugged it's not
plugged into Power compared to a massive
Mac Pro this just blows my mind holy
smokes guys
12343 compared to 591 that's 2.1 times
faster year over year this must be using
raate tracing because that's the only
way to make sense of this insanely good
score and speaking of raid tracing let's
get into blender 3D rendering because we
have blender 4.0 beta which supports
raate tracing so we have this party tug
project right here let's go ahead and
render all right guys this is blowing my
mind because the M3 Max is already done
I'll show you the score in just a minute
but I noticed they were using about the
same amount of wattage for the GPU
around
3233 but this thing's still going does
that mean that rate tracing is just not
using that much more power and guys
you're not going to believe this score
27 1/2 seconds on the M3 Max compared to
a minute on the M2 Max over twice as
fast and the M1 Max which I have took
over a minute and 40 seconds so this
thing's three times faster over three
times faster than that one so basically
if you're doing 3D rendering now that we
have raate tracing this is a must
upgrade for anybody doing 3D work and
here we have Lightroom classic doing our
photo editing export test we have 50 42
megapixel raw images so let's go ahead
and get these exported guys this M3 Max
is absolutely flying it is
mindblowing I've never seen it happen
this fast holy smokes it finished wow
that is a crazy good score the M2 Max is
just about to finish 30 seconds flat for
the M3 Max compared to
46 it's basically 50% faster I have
never seen any machine do this test that
fast and it is blowing my mind I'm sorry
everybody who bought the M2 Max we did
warn you and tell you it was basically a
stop gap for the M3 family because my M1
Max did it in 48 seconds so you
basically got 2 seconds faster on this
thing but 30 seconds on the M3 Max photo
editors you're going to want this
upgrade and now let's move on to video
editing in Final Cut Pro and this first
test is a 5-minute project with 4K HC
footage it's basically the most common
format that people shoot with and edit
today and it looks like they both
finished in a minute and 14 seconds
there's absolutely no difference even
though we saw massive differences in
other tests that's because they have the
same encoder
and that is what the system is limited
by because they're just insanely fast
and now let's go all out and do the
hardest test that we have this is four
streams of 4K Pro res raw which
basically assimilates 8K proor raw and
as you can see there you go you have
four Clips running at the same time so
let's go ahead and get this exported it
looks like they're both running around
the same but the M3 Max is winning
because it does have more GPU power a
little bit more because it looks like
Ray tracing is not being used at all so
the little game that it has in raw
performance is showing some improvements
here this just finished and we have
about 2 minutes 20 seconds for the M3
Max and 2 minutes and 36 for the M2 Max
and this actually looks like around the
same difference that we got in our raw
GPU performance in geekbench because
it's not taking advantage of all those
other gaming GPU features or anything
this is just raw GPU compute so in this
case for video editors it doesn't really
look like it makes sense to upgrade but
the good news is that the M1 Max that I
have took 3 minutes and 35 seconds so
that's actually a pretty big Improvement
for this machine and actually might be a
worthy upgrade if you're doing crazy
video editing like this and now with all
that testing completed let's get into
the conclusion but first I want to show
off these battery life numbers looking
at the M3 Max we have
14% battery and I do want to emphasize
that we've been running it at 600 nits
compared to 500 because it has a
capability and we did actually do more
testing on this machine like for example
in logic where it was surprising us by
how much tracks it was running so we
kept adding more so it drained quite a
bit of battery life there so now let's
look at the M2 Max 5% battery life guys
this is insane even with all of that
extra power even with all the extra
testing that we did and the extra bra
brightess we're still getting better
battery life on the M3 Max this is
blowing my mind the conclusion of this
is wow I am so surprised this is by far
the best M3 family upgrade we've had so
far massive massive difference compared
to M2 Max this is the one that we were
waiting for and apple did such a great
job even if you have the M1 Max I would
say it might even be worth it if you are
looking for a little bit more
performance than what you currently have
and especially if you have an Intel
laptop or something like that this is
such an awesome awesome upgrade so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video let
me know all your thoughts on these tests
down in the comment section below
definitely subscribe for more because we
do have more comparisons coming check
out that video right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one